يو يو
مرحباً Elfonda ، أريد B لـ Mabu Dauntama
لطيف للدخول عارف منقوع
يحفزنا Dauntama Bung Cankta على ذلك
المضي قدما jimung geme soo-ha ummahu jibom
السلام سو ها للذهاب إلى محمد
إنها حقوق عسل طبيعية لمخلوقات الصواريخ
للعسل قبل موضوع الجولة الجديدة
Zayn gemes succinum temasu drum Tama do
ra للعسل. zain gema zushin for
أدخل
مرحبا Sinung lambsle Frozen Milk image
مصل منتخب تحت 16 سنة يدخل مبنى قبة العسل
سنة من علامة Dagen dhammaduta الاتصال
الكذب الميت رائحة تورم tainum
عدد ureung Gema اللعنة لا العسل
يضيف Ainun tbau haynum الشكل البيضاوي الرئيسي
الكونغ فو المجمد للفرن Fandom المجمد
تبغ
مرحبًا اتصل بتوم ، أنا صديق lemmu Umi
تقيؤك الذي لا يخجل من شرب تاما الخاص بك
تأجيل قائمة هيون التبغ ونداما واو هاه
بالنسبة إلى Mayo Nunung ، تطارد تامانو أمباو
واو اسمك أنا
مرحبا مرحبا